foreign
is with us in South Carolina hi Caroline
how are you
good how are y'all better than we
deserve what's up
so I just had a question about buying a
car while we're on baby step two
um we've got about twenty thousand
dollars of debt to pay off
we currently have a 19 year old Honda
Odyssey about 237 000 miles
um great mechanical condition but it is
a salvage title because of hitting the
deer
and our other car is a 16 year old Buick
it's only got 128 000 but we've had to
dump close to 2 000 and do it recently
so I kind of told my husband no more
than maybe another 500 if something
breaks down so I'm just trying to figure
out should we get another car and if so
which of the three options I'm
considering makes the most sense what's
uh what's your household income
um gross is about 90 but take homes only
about 65 to the mandatory retirement
what um
how much debt have you paid off so far
so that's a long story um we just kind
of stumbled back into it accidentally
um I might be an education addict uh we
had actually paid off sixty thousand
um all of my Master's debt and then
I was working on my doctorate and I had
some cash flow issues and stupidly went
back in
okay
and that's the 20 000. yeah
and I should graduate either the summer
or the fall with my doctorate good and
what
education I'm a teacher okay will that
change your pay
yes that will that between that and
South Carolina government's also
proposing so a pretty big pay raise so I
should be looking at probably a ten
thousand dollar bump in the fall nice
very nice okay all right here here
um
is what I heard
you tell me
and um I I I'm saying that because you
get to choose whether I heard you
properly or not because you're the one
saying it
but I heard that every time something
comes up that you want to do
you jump back and forth in and out of
this
I want a car so I'm not going to do baby
step two I want to go get my PhD so I'm
going to go back into debt and you're
never going to break the cycle
as long as you leave options on the
table
to violate the principles
um well I haven't had any trouble except
for education
like we've never had any other no no you
just presented trouble to me again you
wanted to go buy a car while you're
paying off the debt from the last time
you fell off the wagon
yes so this is two breaks in the past
about anything crazy no but this is two
breaks in the pattern listen if you want
to go get a car you go get a car
I would not in your case it has nothing
to do with the cars and has nothing to
do with the financial situation you have
to break this pattern
that's what I think
I think you have a pattern of jumping in
and out depending on what feels good
right now and what you want to do and
I'm telling you you got to plow through
and have the transformation of the way
you view debt and the way you view money
and the way you you know you're not
scared enough about debt yet
you're not freaked out and mad enough
about debt yet
to where you're fighting it like it's
the enemy it's just a casual annoyance
that's what all of your language said as
you were discussing this yeah it's
absolutely right that she's got options
in we take a no option stance and so it
starts to make sense when you make it an
option because then you look at an old
van you go oh we just put two grand in
this I don't want to put any more money
in this you know what there's an option
I can get a loan get a car and that
makes more sense I'd rather put money
into something that's newer that I don't
have to and it's just if I'm gonna quit
eating Donuts I can't have them in the
house right it's not an option probably
not a good idea to drive by the donut
places yeah sometimes that happens but I
keep driving you know I can't turn in
yeah if I turn in it's over yeah I can't
you know if I have them in the house a
hundred percent chance I'm eating them
oh yeah a hundred percent chance now
when I was breaking the cycle what I
would do is get up during covid on the
weekends at six o'clock in the morning I
would go get donuts because nobody was
out right and take them to my grandkids
and I would do that to make myself
handle donuts and not eat one wow and I
did that to to force myself through the
process but now I know that I'm weaker
now than when I was early and more
enthusiastic in the process yeah and I
can't even have them in the house yeah
because I will eat them I'm impressed
that Papa Dave didn't just at one point
at a stoplight reach over and grab one
grab that that's impressive
hot light is on Krispy Kreme and pop
that's my kryptonite I know I couldn't
do it that right there so you're just
telling you all of us my point is I'm no
different Caroline that's correct we all
have this and so you have to have a no
take no prisoners approach to change a
behavior pattern to install a new
principle in your character that you
weren't doing before and you don't have
to take no prisoner's attitude about
this
and that's okay we can still be friends
but you're you're not going to execute
these things well and and with
thoroughness until you do so I would
prescribe no don't buy a car get mad pay
off the debt because the debt standing
between you and getting a decent car
because you're driving a couple pieces
of crap around your house and I'd be
sick and tired of being sick and tired
of driving crap and there's twenty
thousand dollars is in my way and I
gotta get rid of that so I can get an
emergency fund and save up money for a
little better car and I'm gonna go do
that in a very short period of time and
I'm gonna be really angry about it in a
good way yeah I like that by the way I
don't want people to miss what Dave just
said there he it's simple in what he
said but it's pretty profound in that
you change the narrative to I'm kind of
I got a PhD I'm getting a nice job I'm
tired of driving around a piece of crap
so I'm going to save up change my
lifestyle and buy a nice car cash it's a
completely different shift on the focus
and the mindset and it actually works
yeah well you got it you just gotta say
I'm I'm done with this I'm not going to
play games I'm going to play let's see
with this you take the option off the
table I don't go in Banks I don't go in
the donut shop and I don't go into a
bank the only thing banks are for is
making deposits dollar four tell you
what all this talk of donuts I might
stop by the shop on the way home tonight
yeah well just you'll have to shut up
come on Dave talk me out send me a
picture and tell me about it yeah
I thought Dave was going to Cuff me
there folks he's not helping me here
he's not helping me but no it's really
true it it's taking the option off the
table you know I know you and I feel the
same way about marriage and I don't want
anybody to feel guilt or anything of it
but you know committing to one person
you have to take the option off of the
table we're not going to quit yeah
murder is an option but divorce is not
that went a little dark I didn't see
that coming but one of my pastor friends
says you will never hear that he cheated
on his wife you all hear he died
tragically in the home right
it was a tragedy it was a tragedy tragic
well there's an extreme thing because
there is a principle in the principle of
transformation the principle of behavior
modification that you have to and it is
smart to
swing the pendulum way over into crazy
to completely break the cycle in your
brain right and then when he comes back
a little bit it doesn't come all never
wanted to come all the way back because
you're running crazy over on the other
side but when it comes back a little bit
you're relaxed a little bit my budget
has a lot more margin in it than when I
very first started doing a budget and I
was a broke person it was to the penny
yeah and now it's like yeah what you
know but I'm still got a budget still
got a plan right and I used to have
groceries separated from restaurants
because I couldn't right I would we'd go
out to eat and use up the grocery money
and but so I had to have more I had to
swing it more detail more intentionality
more intensity yes but now 30 years of
doing this I mean we've got margin in
the budget number one number two you
know it doesn't matter but you and
Sharon and all the people that have done
this says that you break your appetite
for debt yeah I mean years ago I I'm
gonna break my appetite for living
without a plan I'll always have a plan
exactly but it's it's a I got rid of
sweet tea years ago I can't even drink
it anymore dude you know why because for
about seven years you're not even a real
Southerner I know folks but now I give
up your Southern Man card I know but you
change your appetite
and that's huge you and but you got to
break it's okay with the donuts the tea
just got me I know well that's just my
only thing I like other sweet things but
not the sweet tea anymore it's too much
too much all right we really had sugar
and the tea was an excuse
yeah exactly